if I want the end people to understand
how to manage the failure if you want to
be innovators I'm going to give you what
type of what type of characteristic you
must have see I have the feeling
whenever I do something I feel happy you
you want me you not your memory else by
breaking their limits of their wagon is
a change making the world creativity at
least when he enters the classroom my
teacher I see a radiation of purity of
life the leader should work with the
integrity and succeed with integrity how
did you become so great order of the
nation there is peace of the world he
was the 11th President of India from
2002 to 2007 a career scientist turned
politician he studied physics and
aerospace engineering he was intimately
involved in Indian civilian space
program and missile defense systems he's
APJ Abdul Kalam and here at artists
table Penrose your success we should
know how to handle the not only how to
handle the success how to handle the
failures but really you are in the
management environment you ever turn it
I want the young people to understand
how to manage the failure because any
tasks you do you ought to come across
problem problem should not become the
captain of the individual or a project
chief and the project Chiefs would
become the captain of the problems and
defeat the problem and succeed if you
want with discoverers if you want to be
innovators I am going to give you what
type of what type of characteristic you
must have the invention and discoveries
have you emanated from creative minds
that have been constantly working and
amazing the out of the telephone he was
amazing the outcome you making the
outcome in the mind with imaging and
constantly effort all the forces of the
universe work for that inspired mind
thereby leading to invention displays
see I have the feeling whenever I do
something I feel happy and see this is
you try and that whatever you may have
knowledge you hope sometimes better the
economy you may have better better maybe
sometime you can have a kind words you
can have so if you use and make
somebody's life happy that you are
giving and his or her life is a happy
that's a better best eating a human
being getting off that then you'll get a
card with conflict free world
I learned what did I learn from the
youth of 11 million people I learnt the
ovary youth wants to be unique every
youth to want to be unique that is you
the over you to are to be unique that is
you but the world around that around you
is doing it best day and night to make
you just like everybody else
no no the question is whether you want
to be you or everybody else you you want
to be you not everybody else
now if the quest be like everybody else
is convenient and the first class but
not satisfying in the long vision the
challenge there for my young friends is
that you have to fight the hardest
battle you have to fight the hardest
battle which any human being can ever
imagine to fight and never stop fighting
until you arrive at your destination
this is the unique view history has
proven history has proven that those who
directly imagine impossible are the ones
who break all the human limitations then
your very field of human endeavor
whether science medicine sports arts a
technology the names of the people just
know I listed some of the names the
names of the people imagine the
impossible are engraved in our history
by breaking the limits of the
imagination by breaking their limits of
the imagining the change they change the
world you take CV Raman you take Newton
you take a Einstein you take Chandra
Shekar thereby breaking the limits of
very major imagination they change the
world learning learning use creativity
creativity leads to thinking thinking
provides knowledge knowledge makes you
great you have many accomplishments
you've written books you've served as
president you're aerospace engineer
you've been a professor but you say the
title you like best is the title of
teacher why is that you know I had I had
a teacher when I was a young boy ten
years boy wartime the second world war
going on at that time I used to see in
my class
fifth class teacher in science teacher
he say miss us Subramanya he entered to
the classroom and abused to see the
radiation of knowledge from you
years of knowledge from him when he
enters the classroom my teacher I see a
radiation of purity of life and he's the
way he thought I my dream has got shaped
what should be my way of life he is the
person the teacher gave me the vision of
my life when I was a young fellow
now a teacher has got the fantastic
opportunity to grow minds to enrich the
minds and you that dreams to the young
people and in achieve the dreams with
them and they would become a great human
being
sometime they would become better than
you but better than the teacher so that
happens you do have and also there is a
teacher like what I am doing I am a
professor I can also do the research
young researchers I would be work with
me there's a great pressure when they
get the PhD you're free action of the
leader should be transparent you know
what I mean you said you're very that is
leader should work with integrity and
succeed with integrity you know to work
with integrity and succeed when director
and I I believe president since you
asked the question has to be
continuously in touch with the people
rushed everyone my eyes I was there
became a people smell and stuff Rasta by
the moment it becomes people Superman
and also I travel into the whole state
cutting across deserts and see I was in
touch with the millions and millions of
people how did you become so great great
that's a question well which classes are
Sydney what's your dream in life
[Music]
[Applause]
well you know give the relative terms so
I personally believe you Basava dream
say you must say I must have a dream
I must continuously acquire knowledge
continuously acquire knowledge hard work
hard work and perseverance one should
not be not afraid of problems as you say
in India where there is righteousness in
the heart they have there is
righteousness in the heart there is
beauty in the character when there is
beauty in the character there is harmony
in the home when there is harmony in the
home there is harmony when there is an
order in the nation when there is order
of the nation there is peace in the
world
[Applause]
mr. president Abdul Kalam in the name of
the European Parliament I want to thank
you for this important and inspiring
speech this was one of the most
extraordinary speeches we have ever
heard from a statesman scientist and
poet this is unique all the best to this
great nation India all the best to our
cooperation between the great nation
India and the European Union all the
best mr. president thank you so much for
watching we made this video because
ravichandran substitute once again if
you have things on Twitter that you want
to profile please do below I also love
to know which of the top ten rules that
we mentioned today meant the most to you
and the biggest impact leave in the
comments will join the discussion thank
you so much for watching you need to
believe and we'll see you soon